[Music]
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna get started with this
afternoon session the bootcamp day on
electrical systems power systems and the
first speaker is Sean mine from
university Florida and well they're
about the flow of information great
great thank you very much and thank you
all for Ghana all the organizers and the
staff for making this possible I'm
thrilled to be here is this fantastic
experience so this is a get started a
bit of my own background I think most of
you who know me know me from the big red
book this book by Richard Tweety on the
Markov chains and then 15 years ago at
the University of Illinois I met this
economist in kucho that's not a generic
picture an economist that's and he
actually came to me with the question of
can we try coat the model to understand
the California power crisis and I need
nothing about economics a lot about
stochastic models you know he was The
Economist who worked in the area of and
this you know you know internet cafes
weren't that busy back then and we got
to go to the cafe once a week and try to
cover the model and eventually led to
this paper on dynamics of answering
service prices in power distribution
systems is really we're talking about
transmission but it took us about six
years to get this in a journal because
we didn't realize how inflammatory this
was you know so this was the beginning
of an interesting conversation of
economists for the last 15 years the a
wonderful experience meeting Tom Sargent
at NYU who gave a very kind of view of
my second book on stochastic networks
you know control of networks
he wrote that my earlier book with
Tweetie is the bible for economists
that's his quote I didn't know that so
that's how he felt at the time I don't
know if he feels that way now but today
amongst other things I sort of don't
focus on
economics but on control and in
distributed control in particular with
my colleague Oh beer buit
Florida and on a Bush hitch will be
visiting he'll be arriving here in March
our students I also work in stochastic
control of Markov processes still and so
stay tuned for zap Q&A mr HIV I plan to
get a tutorial on stochastic
approximation in March I think that'll
be valuable for ok to the topic so I'm
gonna basically I'm supposed to talk
about flow of information now I've been
really boring to give a list of all the
signals in the grid so I'm going to talk
about what information signals are
important and also of you a bit of the
dynamics and I'm going to talk about
quite a bit of time to explain how
today's grid is a distributed control
system and it's fascinating there's
nothing else like it there's no massive
control system over and it's a
distributed control architecture that's
a kind of thing that would make a CS
person just jump up and down with joy
it's such a cute in a very sweet
architecture ok
so luckily none of that previous
discussion was heard by anyone and so
then I get so big topic is storage today
California wants to spend billions of
dollars on batteries and I'm going to
talk about that as it is a it is a big
supplier of the signals that are
required in the future ok so first of
all information signal so you know
basically we've got on the grid side we
have energy measured in megawatt hours
and power in megawatts but you'll always
see that messed up so when people you
read an article about batteries they'll
talk about a battery has a hundred
megawatts and you know what they're
talking about
it's huge oh they always has a mistake
there we we you know we've we've heard a
bit about frequency and volts and maybe
not VARs and harmonics and all that
there's right now you know the solar is
hitting California at his wind and
causing a lot of variability and and big
Peaks which I'll talk about and and
ramps and power generation and then and
so that's your nature basically what it
causes and then these people and the
huge gap between what people want and
what the grid operator wants it's so
huge it makes things really hard and so
so you know it's so common sharp pull of
will talk about markets and all that
please we need to work with economists
because so far the money part power is
created it's a commodity like rice and
it's ridiculous you know for so many
reasons I'll hand it some of the reasons
I think it's ridiculous in this talk and
maybe in questions I can explain Laura
it's in terms of I think you know so I'm
gonna start off with this the great
operator so in California you have
California ISO which is in charge of the
markets and most of the control of the
grid in California all the orange bit
and they do a lot of other things too I
won't go through the whole thing they do
things I don't understand what why
they're helping out you create a
generation companies trying to give them
advice ten years in advance it's not
that mandate they do it I don't know it
just is a public service there's lots of
little you know independently on
meanness of balancing regions like
Sacramento SMUD has its own tiny little
balancing Authority so they they're
there if I mean by balancing Authority
is that there's a grid operator that
designs p.i control loops and to control
that part of the grill and to balance
also the
mismatch of power flows between one
balancing area another so they're trying
to make sure that that's
is desire at the power flow and up here
I could have mentioned BPA a lot which
is up in the northwest they're just a
wonderful balance and authority because
they share so much data so we all you
love BPA for sharing all that data
because okay so so one thing that you
know we're concerned about is frequency
and this is an old you know a favorite
example from New York I know so you know
I don't know she doesn't - I think so
yeah 15 years ago
so they lost twenty six hundred
megawatts of power you know so two
billion I know I mean it's incredible
yeah it's uh it's two in sixty million
hundred watt light bulbs I don't know
how all at once and all of it was
because first a circuit breaker you know
you saw circuit breakers and Stephen
Louis talked it it tripped and that
caused some oscillations and transients
and then caused two massive generators
to trip and what happened is this look
at this horrible event stirred it
carefully the frequency went from 60
point zero one Hertz to fifty nine point
nine one five Hertz you know that kind
of tolerance I want that that one Hertz
is enough to completely cause a panic
and you know this could lead to blackout
so you're this tolerance is incredible
and there's a lot of reasons for that
but most power engineers don't even know
why the frequency has to be that tight
if you ask a power engineer at Illinois
you'll get one answer at Berkeley
another answer it because there are a
lot of reasons and some of them enough
irrational why we keep the frequency so
tight I'll get back to that it's
incredible how continuous frequency is a
constant is in it in an interconnected
region so Texas of course it's
completely in Ireland it's it's got
little tie lines DC tie lines to control
power in and out but it's an island it
has its own you know
you know connect there's a a wall here
with a DC toy toys and asked to do it
the geography the big mountains there's
issues with conductivity you know
Stephen low talked about transmission
lines altitude effects physics as well
and so it's easy it's cheaper to just to
cut it off and have DC tar lines between
the western interconnect in the rest of
the country and look at the how tight
the frequency is it's point zero one
Hertz deviation over this entire region
of the Midwest and all or of the of the
west coast so it's remarkable how they
keep that frequency so tight and even
the phase is continuous but what does
that mean I mean estimating phase and
apparently frequency you could always
say phases constant so it's a little bit
of ambiguity there now in other regions
of the world frequency floats more
freely so you don't have that point zero
one or point zero two Hertz you know
constraint in Europe it's it's more like
a Hertz
but at point one Hertz instead of point
O two Hertz and in India this is before
a blackout but frequency can float like
that it can go from you know fifty fifty
point four whatever and the world
doesn't blow up you know and this is
right so when I first taught Power
Systems a till at Florida the University
of Florida my first time teaching it I
was trying to get an understanding of
why in India can you let it float a half
a Hertz in Europe its point one Hertz
and in the United States is point zero
two Hertz and I couldn't get answered
from anyone and finally I got
interviewed every power engineer I knew
in any anywhere in the world and finally
Joe Chow from RPI in New York gave me an
answer and I'll tell you in a second
[Laughter]
I'll tell you the second all right
promise I probably did I forget I don't
mind their fights so here's a really
interesting thing so New York has been
whining about the peak in the afternoon
for decades so you know you've got this
big peak of power 2 p.m. and it's a
nightmare and the reason is you don't
want to a generators want to sell energy
right and they want to be at their it's
sweet spot it might be 80% power and
they want to deliver it constantly they
don't have to withhold 25% just so they
can help put in that peak for a couple
hours you know you know or you can have
a peak or generator sit around and have
it just turn on for a few hours and turn
it off that's real estate and money and
some yes to be there the staff involved
so that little bump is it has been a
nightmare in New York forever and
they've never been able to deal with her
and they've tried prices of devices
they've tried having a you know higher
prices to these Wall Street buildings
and it doesn't work you know they just
don't want to bother with it you know
they it's their power is not their
biggest concern terrible so this thing
has been going forever the Public
Service Commission or Audrey's little
men promised to come in and change
everything and create a more interactive
smart grid which would ideally you'd
like this to come out be flat for you
know 10 hours and come back down not too
steep because as generators have rampion
limits but you like to have that much
more flat and then you wouldn't need as
much reserves for a generation and you
wouldn't you know have much more much
cheaper system yeah
all right way too p.m. um you know a
good question are you somebody somebody
explain that to me once yeah I don't
remember sorry I'll come back to you ok
Oh
it'll-it'll could probably come to me
the store cuz it if somebody told me
this once but everyone you know you have
something similar that's in every region
of the US where you can you get a this
sort of Camelback but the fact that it's
so much bigger 2 p.m. I don't
but nobody noticed this crazy forecaster
so this is the day ahead forecast for
power and that's what they got this was
yesterday this is typical there's a you
know gigawatt there is you know so it's
you know of a 20 gigawatt load so
they're off by you know five percent
that's something new I mean 10 years ago
when I was looking at this I don't I
didn't see five percent errors and I
guess it's because it's more renewables
they have they now have 10 percent wind
and solar as opposed to Florida which
has maybe point one percent renewables
it's terrible I love a lot of things
about Florida some things I can't stand
that's one of them we don't have a noble
portfolio standard but I suspect that
part of the reason for this the forecast
error is that the same is true in
California they the forecast do you have
forecasts for power aren't as good as
they used to be and you can see that
here so this was yesterday the day
before you see the the dashed line there
was the date had forecast for power
you know quantized and that was actually
realized in green thank you I forgot to
say that so this is actual load in New
York State and thank you I was gonna say
it I just forgot to say it thank you
very much please ask questions so this
is the net load and that's why in fact I
forgot to point out this heading so
something that not many of you know many
of you don't know something called the
duck curve in California which has been
predicted for the last seven or eight
years and the idea is that is they bring
more and more solar in so of course is
peaking and you know 1:00 p.m. or
something and and then disappears and it
ramps up in the morning and Grahamstown
the afternoon and what this is showing
is net load so this is the load in
California - where they got from
renewables and that's why this comes
down way more than it would have 10 or
15 years ago this is the you know this
you maybe you can see a duck there I
don't know that's the middle of its back
the prediction arrow is higher than like
10 I'm sure and then that's my that's
all I can think of yeah but this one is
just low right it doesn't yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah you're right I'm sorry
that is just load mistake no is this
always the thing is it that the way this
is just coming out of me right now if I
just saw this yesterday and was shocked
and I've made a mistake so I withdraw
that that's not in that log that's load
so wouldn't be because of that why that
getting bigger forecast errors I don't
know I've got a bad statistician
embedded so the generation is not even
know featuring every solar panel and
every roof adding it together and
subtracting every one of these gross
yeah yeah all right yeah maybe so you
know maybe that's just a as possible but
it is actually net hidden that load yeah
yeah so anyway so this this said what
was that you can unfortunately as
farewell but that's about 5 gigawatts
you know that's me three nuclear
reactors you know you know nobody wants
to grandpa fleet nuclear reactors what
are you gonna do about this so this this
ramp up and ramp down or Grandpop here
ramp up there anyway I'm down as well is
it huge concern to California and so
they really don't know what to do about
it
and they're there's lots of initiatives
to try to deal with it and I don't think
I don't think they're talking to
engineers enough I think they're talking
Economist's and not us and we need to
change that because we need better
policy because I know we can solve this
problem I mean there's no question this
is not this is easier than the problems
faced in telecommunications in the 90s
it's not it's something we will solve
it's just the problem as policy makers
don't talk to us it's just it's
frustrating
a question about the dream okay so yes I
mean I try to argue that in this
presentation that we can the challenges
aren't as as scary as they might look so
this is another again just repeating the
same statement there's a fear of this
duck curved up visits from 2014 people
are predicting the impact of this of
this impact of solar because in problems
they thought it wasn't going to happen
till 2020 and then a year later 2014
they started seeing problems and you see
the prices for power
you know normally they'll be in
California they're like 40 50 dollars
per megawatt-hour
suddenly you're getting spikes to a
thousand dollars a megawatt hour so it's
20 times what it should be because of
the ramp limitation so imagine this
utilities are saying give me power and
the generator is saying we're ramping up
as fast as we can that's when you get a
large multiplier that's when you get
prices spiking and and and that's a
problem no and do you think these little
spikes are going to incentivize the
creation of more responsive generation
anybody think that you built one EPS law
and more responsive generation that peak
will be gone forever okay I guess okay
so will editorial is about markets I
mean markets will not solve that problem
and unless they design very
intelligently yep back to the geographic
situation how many degrees of longitude
do you need to wash that out and what
kind of inter oh god well this thing
isn't this is from this this is from
Arizona and Southern California
everything this is a huge geographic
region and it doesn't wash out much you
know yeah it is true that when you look
at a single solar farm the volatility is
horrendous and so geographic diversity
is incredibly valuable took a grid of
high-frequency disturbances for the fact
that you have a hum for solar power
geographic diversity is going to smooth
it out a bit but not not much
okay so the Pacific Northwest I
mentioned Bonneville Power Authority BP
a wonderful source of data go there and
have fun this is a typical day maybe a
little extreme where you get the full
capacity from the wind farms which is
around 4 gigawatts and the ramped up you
know imagine going from 0 to you know
almost 4 gigawatts in a couple of hours
that is a shock to the system that is
just a bomb going off and yet the thing
still works
they're lucky because they have lots of
hydro you know which is fairly
controllable it's got problems you know
when you try to open up those valves you
get all sorts of turbulence in the in
the dams and stuff so they're not this
dynamic sort of exotic and those issues
right now like it not now in April the
salmon are trying to go upstream and so
you can't dump the water too fast so
you've got the salmon dynamics yogurt as
well it's really something I think
really they get sued every year but it's
the wind farm generation companies see
the fisheries power producers are all
fighting each other but that graph
they've been trying to solve this for
ages and and again it's something we
could help them with a law Germany we
all know about Germany they were so
aggressive after the the earthquake in
Japan in part to to push for you know
more renewable energy they did very
quickly and this is amazing I mean what
year is this 2013 and they've got 40
gigawatts of solar and wind so remember
they the load the peak load in
California's like 30 gigawatts Germany's
big I know but still I mean that's
amazing
and so what people whine about how
Germany is going crazy and they you
can't manage renewable energy well they
went kind of too fast I mean they you
know you put in 80 gigawatts of an
uncontrollable generation and you didn't
have the resources to cushion the blow
yeah it's gonna take some time to get
those resources in place but I think
they will and it's gonna be applauded
for it in the end
now markets are fun to look at
so this is any day you can go to the
midcontinent ISO which is the so it is
so they're basically they control the
auctions in a region and they also play
the role of a balancing Authority so
they they also had the control the
control center and you get these
beautiful price differentials and
regions you know will have a negative
price here maybe negative $20 and a
positive price here maybe ten times the
normal price and obviously it's a
transmission line there okay
and then it'll change and you'll get all
of it everywhere $2,000 may go an hour
and then 15 minutes later it'll be blue
okay and so it's very volatile and
you'll have sometimes you'll have events
like in Texas in 2011 where a couple
generator is tripped and a billions of
dollars we sucked out of the economy in
a few few days you know now billions of
dollars isn't a lot of money when you're
talking about power systems but it's
still it's still real money and yeah and
consumers feel it I was gonna show some
pictures but I don't have time for that
like I have a huge collection of crazy
prices events and the u.s. California
has negative prices too so it was below
minus 50 yesterday in California near
the near the Tijuana border it's
probably because of solar energy I'm
there's lots of solar power the marginal
cost of solar is zero and that's you
know in the market and and then do you
guys do you want me to explain why you
can go negative does anybody want out
and yeah so I I'm a I'm a big gas
turbine generator I've got a staff
sitting there you know and maybe it's
400 megawatts and it's running and
suddenly I mean told I have to pay 50
cents
all right 50 I mean what is it 50 bucks
a megawatt hour to supply power all
right why would I agree to that 400
megawatt generator well it'll happen I
turn off what's gonna happen the prices
the thing is that you know I mean I if I
not only that I'll have to send my staff
home so what happens is you end up
riding it out you just sit there and you
wait hoping the prices will go back up
again because you if you shut that down
you're going home for the day
it'll take you out always to get it back
online and it's costly like with these
really efficient generators if you turn
it off and on too many times you violate
your your contract with General Electric
you know they have they have it stripped
bounds at how many times you can turn
turn off your generator per year you
violate your yeah because they're very
fragile expensive machines so you can't
just turn the thing off and turn it back
on with a really efficient nice one so
little peaker plants you can turn them
on and off you know and we go you have
to have any problems but they're very
inefficient they are very poor he trades
so they take a lot of fuel the same
amount of power
so most efficient generators this we
write it out and these poor nuclear
plants you know you know they definitely
can't shut them down so they're just
sitting there right now the thing is I
don't know why they stay in business
because I checked all week I've been
checking California or so and near
Tijuana seems to almost always be
negative in the middle of the day it's
when I'm generating this extra power
I'm negative
just think is it I have no other
resource if if only I had a some place
to dump this power you know if I was a
generator you'd be so cool
if I had a battery over there and I
could just flip the switch and fill up
the battery with energy you know but I
don't have the resource so all I can do
my only resource to dump my power is the
grid itself and so I'm paying $50 an
hour to California or so for the to use
them as a battery just to dump my power
it's a lousy battery cuz I can't get it
back you know I don't get I don't get to
get the energy back I'll just dump
enough well some people are shutting
down you know and yeah and the grid does
have incredible capacity buffer capacity
in the sense that you saw that two
gigawatt draw the grid and display off
it was able to think things were able to
stabilize that
oh it was just a yeah I mean if you look
at that yeah it's just that think about
that it was only during a little peek of
it Maxima slope that it went up these
these these auctions are every five
minutes for an hour in the future and it
might just be this isn't real time this
is someone's opinion about what the
situation will be an hour for them well
there's an auction every five minutes
for commitments an hour from now okay
it's not an actual imbalance in the
power system it's a difference of
opinion
Wow oh boy is that an issue - yes that
is true
yep absol is a difference there's all
sorts of reserve requirements and so
forth and this is it's based on a
forecast absolutely yeah and there's a
lot of weird things here and then Texas
is wonderful look at so wait if you ever
go so those of you are students of this
if you ever go to the Texas website
you'll you'll look at this and say
nothing's happening today it's all blue
and that's because you have to look at
the scale it goes from nine thousand
dollars a megawatt hour normally it's
thirty it's a delta - 250 and and why is
it nine thousand dollars a megawatt hour
it used to be three thousand but after
the 2011 crisis they did a study and
they decided the price cap was too low
and they raised it to $9,000 $9,000 a
megawatt hour so after the the
generation companies made this windfall
profits record in the US probably they
agree as the price caps is the solution
you know now there is a problem to solve
but I'm not sure that's the way
now I'm on the side of the generators
and I'll show you why this is called
normal gradient you zoom in to high
gradient this is what it looked like
yesterday noon and the highest most
expensive power in all of Texas was 23
24 bucks a megawatt hour that's below
cost
that's like negative and the lowest was
minus 23 this is not sustainable Texas
will not survive you know and it's
because you've got all this wind often
in West Texas or no and Oklahoma and and
you know what will happen if all these
generators go out of business it might
be great if it's windy and sunny for
three months and then the winds gonna
die and you're not gonna get these
trailers back again we need them you
know at some point maybe we won't but if
we keep this up and it's like this it's
been like this like every day for years
and then we do so it's very sources yeah
that's the goal but the thing is that if
we if we all do an analysis of well that
really incentivize anything I think we
find out it's impossible and doesn't
reward the right people who ever happen
to be lucky enough to be at the right
time gets $9,000 and people have
previously committed don't get the
$9,000 so the people who are good
citizens you know provided 90 percent of
capacity because they wanted to help the
grid they lose out and they they're
they're the valuable citizens you should
be rewarded it's a weird they did
strange like yeah
yeah that's a lot of wind well there's a
lot of wind here and I'm not sure up
here too but that's yeah and it goes
negative because of renewables well they
don't want them to they do but Texas
does Texas Walker tailwind if there's a
if there issues a Bonneville Power
Authority made some very naive contracts
with wind generation and so it's not
allowed to curtail wind that's still
being fought in courts because they they
can so I see it so I'm the thing is that
when get some subsidies no matter what
so even though they pay the negative
price they're getting they're getting
extra money so yeah that's another
problem so this is just one example of
the prices did go up to four thousand
dollars a megawatt hour so it's a
hundred times larger than normal and
it's there's lots of examples of this I
just wasn't sure it was just an again
it's gone up for more than that I just
don't have the data okay so why is it
balancing authorities so picky about
frequency so I I learned to this before
and the this is more really let's think
about the generators point of view so
this is a one of the new generators in
Florida and it's a it's a type of their
combined cycle it's a combined cycle gas
turbine generator that's C C naught C T
and these are the most expensive
generators in the world and the most
efficient and for de has all of them I
mean you know all the generators are
this so Florida has the cheapest Texas
in Florida the cheapest power in the
u.s. Florida is a completely vertical
you know
it's a duopoly baby basically it's
vertically integrated and Texas is
completely well wild well blast it so
it's it's a deregulated system but these
guys are really really expensive and
very very fragile and you have to really
treat them with care so the most
efficient generators are the most
fragile so these so you know basically
how it's CT you know it's funny sees the
co2 combined cycle gas turbine
generators they're efficient expensive
and dainty so they trip if the frequency
goes out of bounds and what I was told
or my friend in New York is that they're
incredibly they have many many modes of
oscillation and and different generators
have different modes at which they might
oscillate and and that oscillation can
destroy a billion-dollar generator and
so these generators will trip to save
themselves and the balancing Authority
knows this and so they're enforcing
incredibly strict standards on quality
of power just because of a few you know
of these fussy generators but Joe coward
yeah but let's have this debate
separately because this is the only
rational explanation yeah but well yeah
but Joe Chow says that this is the
standards that General Electric imposes
you know and this visit of powers is the
only power engineer who's able to give
me an answer that can make sense though
because why do we keep two point zero to
3 Hertz I ask pizza or Tom of everyone I
know and Bower and and nobody could give
me an answer except for it you know do a
job
but that may be the wrong answer yeah
but Kirby he wasn't our creature he says
he has a new one started why
historically evolved because auditing
requirements from nature yes well the
thing is that the generation companies
imposes I know it's part of the the
warranties as I mentioned I know that's
true but this is they do trip if they go
out of bounds and a generation companies
do the belt Authority knows this and
they don't want anybody to trip and so
it may be that we could get away with
much sloppy control with different rules
and different you know they don't have
yet they don't buy these billion-dollar
units yeah yeah he's uh these fancy
units or not as far as I know not in how
did you know traditionally though there
was the constraint on electric clocks oh
yes I love the frequency was they would
resent it every hour or whatever they
would they would make sure that every
hour you got exactly the right number of
cycles now control really such a huge
cost anyway rule set points that we
generate
people gets burnt in system there's not
really a function it's a good question
but it is driving a lot of policy
keeping the frequencies no tired the joy
in terms of what does it really cost for
good control well we'll come back to
that too actually well topic for
discussion
this way to a silly question this is
gender it directs it generates a
slightly different frequency than some
other generator
yeah they don't they're these guys are
locked it's almost like they're
physically connected by a bar you know
they're really locked in in place of it
there's a slight change in speeds
that's right so but the generation
companies are being tortured and we
really need them so they're not the
enemy they're really not the enemy
I mean they talk about droop in a moment
and EGC oh it's don't define it in a
moment and they're asked to provide a
ramping services not these delicate
babies but other generators and then not
really there's no way of compensating
for the poor so it's really an issue
right now yeah okay so I'm gonna move on
so what about you guys so you all
consume power we're consuming power
right now I can see it and I'm gonna ask
you all to take a quality-of-life test
and this is going to help to defeat into
some other discussion so how would you
feel if a stranger unplugged your
computer or just turned off the lights
so basically that happened at time T
naught and you were happy and how would
you sketch in this plot and it would
depend of course but you've got a you've
got a deadline for proposal or something
like that and you know you'd look like
that today you know I mean it's of
course all right so that's a rational
agent would scream if you pull the plug
in the computer for this you know
obviously there are other loads where it
might be different so you refrigerator
your water heater your pool pump if you
have a pool pump so there's a million of
them in California so I bet a few of you
have one
and you know it'd be different right and
i conject it would look just like that
yeah you pull the plug in my fridge you
plug it back in in ten minutes okay it's
nothing it doesn't mean anything to you
and the same is true for water heaters
and pool pumps well plug my pool pump
for a week I don't care or doubt week to
days
I don't care yeah yeah no the thing is
it's about of timescales which I'll talk
about its yeah and that's yeah that's
why I put it so for a pool pump this
would be 48 hours for a fridge this
would be 30 minutes for water heater
this would be 2 hours so the thing is
these are all flexible loads but
flexible does not mean dispensable they
can just share the power can be shifted
okay and it's because of thermal inertia
or the time constants of algae and so
there's a form of storage you know I
mean I've got a budget for getting rid
of algae you know and I can use it now
or I can wait a bit and use it later
that budget is storage and ok so I want
to you know basically that's one thing
we should be discussed for the next
months is how to make use of this
mismatch between power and and what the
consumer wants is really valuable you
know the fact that they're flexible okay
so let's go through to a crash course in
control so I'm going to talk about I'm
not going to get in a lot of details but
you talk about the magic of distributed
control today so first of all flight
control the analogy is almost perfect
for one airplane so you've got an
airplane I don't know what about your
space engineering but you've got an
airplane and they have a lawns and flaps
and elevators things that move up and
down and and there are nonlinear devices
but what they've learned is is that if
they put in local feedback loops so they
put in little local feedback loops
completely like that you know basically
local measurements of angle and and low
in measurements of where you want the
angle to be you can linearize the
dynamic
and then it makes you know the reason
for that is it simplifies control from
the the flight control system then the
linearity assumption is valid because
you've linearized up with to this local
control it simplifies everything
immensely now the same thing happens in
the grid and their multiple analogy that
can make so here's the grid right so
you've got a balancing Authority which
is there beautiful to see just millions
of dollars in displays and computers and
they have old-fashioned telephone so
they pick up calls and call generation
they do and they have a grid the grid
are the generators you know these big
generators and the generators are
analogous to jet engine it's not an
airplane the answer services are what
actuate a command for the balancing
Authority ramp up how a ramp down ramp
up grant down those are called ancillary
services that just like the flux in an
airplane driving it into your brain you
know so managing the grid is like flying
an airplane and we think it's really
useful can you think about how robust
flight control is we flight these in
crazy storms and you know how many
people died last year in the u.s. in
flight you know flight crashes did you
hear that yeah zero I mean the
reliability considering what a horrible
how much how many this negative the
disturbances of airplanes face we should
be able to control the grid if we can
control airplane all right okay so don't
forget I expect all of you now control
experts you saw Richard Murray's talk
and you know that P I control is like
the ninety five percent of what's used
you all know what a bode plot is and a
step response right alright y'all so
that yep so this this looks like it's
this look four million a moment that
oscillatory behavior is something you
see in Grant's all the time don't forget
that and don't forget this that
frequency is constant over a region all
the time I mean if there's a crazy you
and
clear bomb lands in the Illinois yeah I
won't be constant I mean it's always
constant I mean it's it's might be off
by point zero three Hertz from here to
here but that's all it's amazing so you
you must feel excited about what I mean
to say you know imagine having a global
signal you know for control it's
fantastic so that's what that's what
makes the good work the fact that you
have a signal that's global and doesn't
have to be communicated which is
something that Stephen lo is pointing
out you can use for other purposes it is
incredible for controlling the grid so
don't forget that so let's do it crash
course in control so number one you've
got this this big block diagram don't
worry about it mainly don't forget that
frequency system frequency is a global
you know quantity which everybody can
measure and what the generators have is
a governor and when they see deviation
and frequency they'll open up the valves
more will reduce them more depending and
it's almost Pai control it's a
stabilized integral controller it's what
it is okay so there's a static analysis
you'll mainly see in textbooks but this
is like the aileron fit trick this is
like a little feedback loop at every
generator to make the aggregate behavior
nicer that's it so each one measures
frequency and adjusts this is the static
analysis it says this will help you not
deviate too much in frequency but the
dynamics are being shaped as well so
details of blocks are important just as
important as you're measuring frequency
adjusting the amount of fuel going into
the generator in response then you've
got the balancing Authority which
measures what's called tie line errors
the error and what was scheduled and was
actually flowing between balanced
authorities and system frequencies puts
it through a PI controller you know
thank you Richard Murray and then sends
that every generator they're all getting
the same signal scale
and then you got that's it you know
you've basically you've got a bunch of
errors there because how many generators
were there Stephen thousands and VIN you
know in California it's less spitting oh
there's a lot of generators and they're
all getting you know it's sending their
signals into this big grid with
transportation I mean with transmission
and all that and then the thing goes
around that's it that's your crash
course because this is the main ideas
okay so the question they ask is why
this architecture and how do you model
the aggregate input output system you
know the AGC is collected called
something called automatic generation
control AGC is what comes out of it from
the balancing Authority that's the input
to all the generators the output is
frequency you want to model it and put
output system you know those are
questions we'll answer them already
you know I mean they weren't inspired by
flight control but you are it's just
like an airplane so all the local
control makes the aggregate a really
simple my system and it makes this
balance Authority's job very very easy
so if you look at for example Texas and
you come up with a reasonable model of
air cough that you know the region in
Texas it is the most boring boat
frequency of port sports you can imagine
the zero is a normalization it's just a
flat gain and then falls off and you
might say it's a fifth order system and
then graph that you say forget it second
order and it's only second order because
the phase goes down to minus 180 and
that's an approximation but it's just
becomes a static and and so the balance
authorities drop it quite easy now this
game might change depending on load
conditions and all that so there's some
adaptation involved so if you look at
the kind of model you get you can
validate it based on an event so these
are simulated events we've seen lose 2
gigawatts of load generation or gain 2
gigawatts of load and what this is is a
member Richard Murray step response this
is an upside-down step response because
you lost something
and what happens is in Texas for
regional model you go to the frequency
goes down that comes up and it goes to a
steady-state value yes if the balancing
Authority isn't saying hey step on the
gas in reality the balance authorities
saying hey and they're using P I control
so they're trying to bring the frequency
back up so this actually goes back up
like this these are simulations from
wack from the Western Europe
interconnect so this would be if the
balance if though he didn't do anything
after a loss of low loss of generation
okay in fact they have P I control so
they measure the AIRAID frequency and
they integrate that error and send a
signal so Narracott this would come back
up and so in terms of control so those
of you now all of you experts now in p
a-- control if you were given this bode
plot is that this means there's a lot of
uncertainty of high frequencies what
control architecture would you use to
stabilize control the system and and our
goal is to make sure to get the
frequency back to sixty Hertz the
authority
is that I think I heard that fuzzy logic
I know that work yeah controller first
yeah so basically you want to crank up
the Gannet low frequency that's key I
control and they don't even need the P
it's a pure indigo control it's going
and that's that's it so basically you
just usually control this cranks up the
gain and make sure you get a bandwidth
around here not too high you want to
suppress again high frequencies because
you have a lot of uncertainty there the
balance authorities job seems trivial
yeah of course it's not of course
they're issues I'm just I'm giving you a
high level alright so this is what it
looks like so again you know they
measure these tie line areas between
balancing authorities and they measure
frequency deviation they put it through
API controller then it goes out to all
the generators three different scalings
four different generators and and this
is what it looks like
so in PGM you know in the East Coast
what they do is they take it and they
break into two parts which I think was a
brilliant move they have what's called
raggedy the dynamic regulation which is
a higher frequency content and it's way
more constrained in terms of energy so
you integrate the energy over I remember
if it's ten minutes or an hour it's zero
and they do that because they send these
two batteries which have energy
constraints you know they they they can
go up and down but they they can't
produce energy or they have they have
some losses but but the batteries have
to take care of their losses so if
they're if they have losses up to buy in
at you know so a great DEA's exactly
zero main reggae is not so tightly
constrained and they didn't forget
counting reasons but it was also turned
to be very valuable for engineering
because you could take the blue stuff
and send it to the very very accurate
resources like batteries and the good
thing you could send to traditional
generators that could ramp up and down
very good story here a lot of time but
yep just yeah clarify things when you
were earlier talking about auctions
we've had this one hour delay yeah here
we're dealing is real time real time
what is the time oh yeah thank you thank
you
so basically this is every four seconds
so they send out a signal every four
seconds the bandwidth the signals is
much lower so you know it's like if you
look at this that's this is two hours
and so the frequency content is really
more in the minute scale say before
seconds and that's just because of
control we like to sample yes all I said
no I haven't done that I don't think
what they did is that it's a long story
about mandates to pay for performance my
buddies will give the accounting
it's called FERC order 755 and they were
forced to pay for performance and and
they found it too costly so he did this
a clever accounting trick and they took
a high-frequency part which is rig D reg
D is the faster one where that is read
that is higher frequency content and
they said this is what will pay
performance for this red part and
there's higher frequency content and
it's also normalized to be zero zero
energy over a period of I don't remember
and this is the residual so the sum of
these two was the output of the PID
controller this is basically great thing
you can think of it as the this put
through a high-pass filter and also
normalized of zero mean now you go over
to bell the balancing reserves at
Bonneville Power Authority you see
something very different you've got well
first of all you've got this this is
what sent to the generator is on a
windless day and this is what sentence
generators in a day with a lot of wind
and it's bigger but it's not a lot
bigger so you know it's not a huge
difference with this almost 4 gigawatts
of wind we see some bigger excursions of
the signal sent of the generators but
you know it's not catastrophic what you
will notice though is this huge low
frequency content so those other things
were up down up down every few minutes
this is you have basically if you did a
Fourier transform and looked at periods
of three hours you'd see a lot of
content and the reason is is that this
auction doesn't exist
so in BPA they don't have a real-time
market and they and they treat
everything as flaps on the airplane and
they do Richard Murray does they have
that that UD discuss they have the
trajectory plan they have wind
forecasting errors and all of this all
this forecast air that's put into this
this is a very complicated signal it's
way more than a GC and I think this is
the way to go if it's a zero energy
signal why pretend it's an energy market
there's what I've been saying for 15
years and I've never gotten an answer
why would you look at this and say we
need an energy market to provide this
service I don't understand it but that's
what's done in California and Texas and
New York they take this and they have
energy markets every five minutes so I
know I'm supposed to just about the flow
of you know flow of information well the
dollar signs
but you know if you're a control person
I don't want an account in the loop I
want to take this and bring over Richard
Murray and call Esther them and do this
right we can we can you know deal with a
volatility by good control we need
resources for actuation the question is
how to get them all right and the thing
is that generate is to allows a job very
often because they partly don't have any
incentive so Brendon Kirby was mentioned
there's a wonderful paper that's right
I've got a reference for you from
Brandon Kirby that shows what's
requested from the generators and what's
delivered he's a really good generator
here's one that's terrible and you see
this incredible phase shift between what
was requested what was delivered we've
done enough of it so if six is Brandon
Kirby's it wasn't for paper I think
we've done analysis on this and because
it's such a simple system
there's NU'EST of stability but it's
costly so if everyone's messing up okay
if everyone who homogeneous suppose it
everybody introduce a phase lag of 20
degrees no problem at all nothing but if
the problem is if they all different
some are have a phase lead of 27 fees
lag of 20 they can't see each other out
so you need morale overall and so the
more so there's a cost to answer to the
lack of homogeny imaginative resources
so here's their job simple so the thing
is let's get to the last part of the
talk they need answer services that's
what these are called to provide this
actuation you've got something like a
flight control system they don't have
they can't go and buy ailerons now
that's the problem there are lots of
solutions if we start with generators
we've got gas combustion generators and
haider the the great terms of
responsiveness gas combustion those are
not the combined cycle
those are peaker plants they're not
cheap you know and they use gas and
you've got to grab them up and down they
get he use have a pollution will be
higher it's all sorts of funny things
that
are being used and proposed I love the
idea of playing trains uphill that's
actually being used for storage
longer-term storage and you know molten
souls all sorts of things it's a mandate
you know you know the thing is that
there was no it was like Don't Ask Don't
Tell
until recently now they're starting to
try to push things but so far they've
only been real penalties against the
higher frequent like the the battery
companies at all about you know
basically they'll get yelled at if they
if they flip the sign of their governor
the wrong direction or something you
know they say we won't do it next time
but if they understood the cost
I think there'd be more strict rules in
place okay so yeah so the thing is a
California has mandated billions of
dollars on batteries utilities have to
buy these batteries and they get to put
in their rate base so they'll end up
charging you guys who live here and you
know I think that it's a discussion we
have to have is that is this a good idea
I mean should we be spending billions of
dollars on batteries I think it's a
mistake I think we could use them and I
think we should do research on battery
technology but I don't think it's ready
yet I think we should wait so basically
I'm going to talk about virtual energy
storage it's something that a lot of us
in the room of worked on and the fantasy
is just to basically take a bunch of
loads send a signal to the loads and the
output power deviation is just what a
battery would do charge discharge charge
discharge that's the dream you know
signals broadcast you have a water
heater in California and they all see it
and the ensemble goes up and down just
like it
and so base off work to this for ages I
mean I mean I gotta give a talk on this
on Wednesday I won't talk about much
here this is this an advertisement for
next Wednesday's lecture 10:00 a.m. I'm
not sure the location but basically
putting lots of local intelligence at
the load again like the a low on example
and and that way try to make the
aggregate behavior look really nice and
simple and there's a to undergraduates
that helped me build a smart little
thank you for you
okay so batteries the preferred solution
in a golden stage
they're awesome except a lot of accepts
they're costly they waste energy I think
10 percent is the best in terms of
weight in one cycle you throw away 10%
of the energy went through and there's a
lot of real estate required you need a
Walmart so you have one of these big
battery systems as big as a Walmart and
China now Google China Chile lithium
you'll get a thousand hits they want to
own a Chile lithium has become such a
it's gold now because of the fact that
there's this this thought that we're all
going to put you know massive batteries
everywhere and so we're going to need
tons of lithium and guess what we got to
swap it out every three years you know
oh your technology will improve of
course but with current technology
you'll have to swap it out every three
years and also they're very eccentrics
of people that preferred choices lithium
ion batteries but if you look at the the
discharge charge profile the lithium ion
battery they can discharge really fast
you know but then they're very very slow
to charge it's a nickel metal hydride
batteries can do more of a square wave
like this a more symmetric but this this
means you'll need a lot more batteries
than you think because in order to get
the amount of of sucking in power that
you want the grade of sucking in power
which you want which you want you
because maybe we have ramps up and down
and the battery so or to deal with those
rounds so to be able to suck up a lot of
power quickly in the morning you could
have to get a lot of generator batteries
to bring that up
so leave that mine batteries are great
but they have not perfect and so yeah I
mean to get lithium-ion batteries to
four riggidy you're gonna waste a lot of
capacity because of this asymmetry right
so when when they charge and they
consume 10 megawatts of power where they
discharging the discharging ten times
that the city of symmetry well the
signals to be tractor symmetric I see
some confused faces
that's a maxima graded which I can suck
power in in and that's the rate at which
I can send it out asymmetry is it
expensive okay so demand dispatch is a
term that was coined by Google and
Indesit of a position paper many years
ago they didn't really have any science
behind it but they just were looking for
new language and the reason is the
demand response if you look at if you
google that you'll get one definition
its load shedding in exchange for a
payment that's what you get on the DEA
website and we're talk about something
completely different we're talking about
nobody feel anything not loadshedding
we're just talking about you know
exploiting the inherent storage it's in
this building right now this is a huge
amount of thermal inertia this building
one paper that really one bit of work
that they got people going was French
weapons a pata kiddin to have happened
on refrigerators water heaters looking
at local frequency and then tripping
when the frequency went full of official
and or turning on or off and this patent
didn't go anywhere and you know why
right
got homogeneous collection of a million
refrigerators I told you a frequency is
constant you know they're all going to
turn off at the same time it's a coming
explosion so this this might not have
been the best approach but it really
inspired people so in particular on
malam a developed ideas for thinking
about a large collection of loads and
how to model an aggregate of loads
that's the mean field model II hear you
hear a lot about in this area so that
mean field model is this gold you know I
mean it's a natural natural thing to do
but that he came with the word we know
the first first papers on this and then
you know that this issue I mentioned the
problem with Sharpay's patent really you
know obviously if he led to thoughts
about young use of randomized strategies
and Duncan Calloway here and even his
contempt is now at Michigan and a host
of other people have developed
randomized control over walls if I try
to deal with the synchronization issue
in any you know I mean I I hate that
self-advertisement but my colleague on a
[ __ ] she'll be arriving in March and
we've been working on this for the last
five years I've published a dozen papers
it's not now when I first talked about
this with people in industry it was like
2013 and they laughed at me I remember
at distribute tech they said don't ever
use that word in public but now you know
so these guys now have patents on they
were just saying this because they
didn't want me in the room so Snyder and
essence see these big utility companies
their building randomization into
equipment for example this is a patent
for an HVAC unit when it sees a voltage
deviation it'll trip no randomization
there I don't know why that's a mistake
and then it they generate when the
voltage was is restored it generates
they exponentially distributed random
variable and turns on with that clock
ends and that avoids everybody tween on
at once so so the fact that these these
patents are out there means we can talk
to industry now and there
laughs is out of the room now it's been
this this idea of using putting
consumers in the loop has been around
forever and it's been successful the
failures in California with real-time
prices to old ladies in Bakersfield
there was just a bad experiment in
Florida we've been doing this for 30
years
there's contracts with consumers so you
can shed load from water heaters and
pool pumps etcetera wait for
contingencies um
EDF electricity to France they have a
lot of nuclear power what do you do with
nuclear power at night they dump it in a
water heaters so they have regions have
really hot water in life because because
either you have dumps electricity and I
don't find out recently the New Zealand
did this before a France if they they
have some trick tricks to dump done
power and contingency reserves so it's
been around a long time
UK has not been as creative and of
course is all these these new companies
you know there's in an arc and an opal
and and ball I mean and all sorts of
things and that's you'll see here got a
big business and here I put potential
you know because we don't know yet if
he's always equipped all these
businesses will fail or not okay so I'm
just gonna close I'll make this quick I
I have 20 minutes but I can see you all
getting tired I'm just gonna go through
and talk about a few of the issues real
quick I think you skip over this really
quick because it's pretty obvious what
you do with buildings this is my
colleague Kirby Oberoi
we did our first experiments in 2011
this building at the University of
Florida it's one of the reasons I ended
up at Florida was because of these work
with Revere and just jump ahead and
forget it you know basically you can
track a reg D signal perfectly by
modulating fan speeds up and down it
doesn't affect anybody nobody feels a
thing if you look at the fans before and
after we got involved they don't look
any different
it's just nothing it's nothing
absolutely nothing and this building
automation equipment in the
in the building so you just have to
write a few scripts of code it's nothing
you know and this noise is just
measurement noise we just didn't have
the money for good sensors get the zero
line to be in the middle of this graph I
mean that fan is not actually giving
energy back to the grid well this is dog
this is starting the measurements we
start missions at zero and we know oh I
mean the fan is not like a battery can't
actually return power to it yes you can
make its deviate its increasing it to be
ten percent decrease in to the extent
that amis can't but the zero line is
actually a consumption though it doesn't
matter though but what the balance in
thought he wants they want deviation
they don't they don't care at all about
the power consumption they care about
deviation so this this is better than
any battery could ever do the services
is the service is much better than
anybody would provide you know know it's
it's yeah it's deviation that we care
about yes there is a reference we
subtracted off the power consumption at
that time is there there yes there are
the reference we subtracted off the
constant power there would have been in
terms of commodities financial market
charting that's a straight commodity
chart and I just naturally because the
only weight exploited studied for over
three decades I just look all these
charts do those analysis automatically
but that's a straight okay thank you Oh
Bela pet okay yeah but I just want to
say that was a hundred buildings you get
a megawatt of power up and down capacity
for Ag Dean and that's with this ten
percent of the fan so the University of
Florida could basically by all of the
Reg deviates of PJM and without anything
you know so it's it's amazing what you
can get for nothing um but I think it's
more fun to us to briefly talk about
water heaters but it's so amazing how
many of you know that that's what your
water heat is doing it's a wham four
point five kilowatts you know zero for
four to six hours wham four point six
kilowatts
off you know
but your temperature is this going up
and down you know it shoots up and goes
down and shoots up and it goes down and
you're not aware of that either you just
you're not aware that's actually
deviating but that pulse train of power
is what's so valuable it has nothing to
do with you or the thing that you're
purchasing it you want is hot water
which is almost apparent no apparent
relationship with this pulse train and
that's incredibly valuable for harness
and water use for virtual storage so in
terms of capacity is again this baseline
issue so basically if you looked at a
bunch of water here's a hundred thousand
of them with with nobody around they'd
be consuming 30 megawatts of power and
the peak is ridiculously how I forget
that and so in terms of the capacity
it's really relative to that baseline so
you could turn them all off and that
would be the average with 30 megawatts
you could turn them all on if you wanted
to suck power l but you're not gonna do
that
look at this you know it's too much
that's just the upper bound is
ridiculous in terms of energy capacity
there's some really nice work with
Thomas Rowe and colleagues but think
about here's another way of thinking
about it how would I major the energy
capacity of a bunch of water heaters
well think about fully charging this
storage what does that mean how would I
mean by fully charge I had a thousand
water heaters well it means dumping in
energy until they reach their max max
temperature so get them all to their
highest temperature and then pull the
plug it's just a thought experiment I'm
not going to do this and pull the plug
until the temperature gets down to the
lower limit energy is power times time
so at time zero I had mult the highest
temperature I pulled the plug I waited
until it got to the lowest temperature
and that time there is how much time I
was able to go from the 30 megawatts to
zero you know and I multiplied time
Dontae average power that's energy and
what's amazing is it agrees almost
exactly with a formula for using
different methods paper
come ashore on all you know so energy is
x times power sits home constants of the
unit are gonna tell us this and so in
terms of you have a via HUD and xx oh I
could take a hundred twenty thousand
sorry residential water heaters I'm
going to work this all out now I'm gonna
find is it with a hundred twenty
thousand residential water heaters I
have a 30 megawatt 121 megawatt hour
battery system now why did I pick those
numbers it's because last spring a year
ago they installed the largest lithium
ion battery in the world in Escondido
Southern California and how do we
compare so basically we pick this number
so these numbers would match up so this
this little baby you know that you can
put in your pocket is like a hundred
twenty thousand water heaters it's cute
- all right you could pick this up you
can put it on your desk it may be so
impressed well not really though because
it's really this huge system massive
thing and it's got a big HVAC system to
keep the thing cool you know and it
wastes ten percent of the energy
round-trip that's been generous I don't
know what kind of they're not telling us
what kind of batteries we have what
efficiency ratings they are it's cooling
acquired and they're lithium-ion
batteries so they're not 30 megawatts
they might be 30 megawatts one direction
and only two megawatts the other
direction so I don't know they won't
tell us but it turns out stop - anymore
there's Tesla Elon Musk created a 129
megawatt hour battery Australia west
last December so by nine megawatt hours
it's bigger in Australia now but so the
thing is that this is this is awesome
because I mean do the account in there
are 40 million people in California
there a good reason for incentivizing
gas water heaters back then but now it
makes a lot more sense of an electric
and if this this valuable for storage
then why don't we do it
you know lots of hot tubs I'm told and
we've done the accounting
I grant conjecture and I'm really sure
it's true that it'd be at least half
price to take buy 120,000 water heaters
from Costco give them a get somebody to
give them two houses and Escondido set
up the equipment put in the interface
and communication hardware and the cost
would be half and you wouldn't have to
replace them every three year it's been
how long do the hot water here with us
it's just incredible how cheap it is now
maybe you know storage will get cheaper
and then we can do this but why are we
rushing I don't understand it so you
know all right
so in terms of Quebec achieving capacity
we'll briefly this is what happens with
a particular control strategy where
here's no reference signal to a hundred
thousand water heaters here's one scale
to plus or minus 10 megawatts and here's
scale to plus or minus 40 megawatts and
here's one of the loads Pinkett taking
orbit early what it what how it behaves
normally with no no interference when
the ensembles fall in a regulation
signal and when it's been abused because
this was not feasible the signal being
minus 40 would be not just trade off you
know everybody off the train with your
free times it wasn't feasible but you
don't see any difference between the
individual behavior at all it's because
you're just shifting things around a
little bit
to be able to follow the signal that's
what heaters are really cool for that
reason okay and so anyway we can do
other things too and with pool pumps you
can do amazing things contingencies and
all those I'm out of time and there's a
project with Department of Energy to try
to estimate the capacity in terms of
energy and and they go in
energy power in various regions of the
country that's ongoing alright so just
in terms of last words
so that that's this is for Wednesday so
there's a question that sort of fun is
that well can we do is this because I'm
last-minute questions can fridges
provide droop like generators do the
thing is that my very first power energy
systems meeting I heard this wonderful
lecture or a connection at arrayed by
this old-time power engineer saying
fridges used to provide droop
old-fashioned fridges had motors
connected directly to their system if
the frequency went down they slowed down
they were just like generators providing
I mean since the inertia and droop and
he said was incredible resource but if
we could if they did it through you know
big iron spinning machines you could do
it power electronics oh I bet you could
do it you know what it's the best way to
do it I don't know but these like Oh
image to the for that you for voltage
control I think loads be more useful
maybe we'll see what do we do if we lose
a mega this Nirvana we all think about
of wind and and and solar and nothing
else
which is maybe conceivable but we won't
we'll lose our Omega I'm the reason that
Omega is constant is these big spinning
machines in the inertia and I don't
think power electronics Nimet Carla
trikes engineers love to brag about how
they can do anything I don't think they
can make the frequency constant all over
the US they're electronic so long I just
I don't know it doesn't seem physical to
me but and do we need it I don't know if
we need it you know if we could provide
synthetic inertia to send a control
signal Mabel does have to be a singer
control architecture who knows this is
50 years out but it's interesting to
think about now but voltage is not going
to be a replacement accepted very small
micro good setting there's some work by
Stephen Lo and others on other
approaches to consensus there's issues
of estimation this question of baseline
is a philosophical question so what you
would have kin
assumed if you hadn't been enrolled in
this program it's just always going to
be open to disputes get the consumers
out of the loop you know just forget
that question you know we just went up
we're engineers we will measure the
physical system and see if we get the
deviations our measurements that we
expect from the aggregate not
individuals this issues an estimated
state of charge but for real batteries
and virtual batteries there's nice work
again at Berkeley on this and for water
heat it's like the average temperature
but there's an estimation problem either
the balance of 30 would like to estimate
that quantity still I'd still call it an
open question there's a cost to
consumers which I won't talk about now
there's a value of tracking my dream
forget that my dream is this is let's
say track e doesn't have to be that good
anyway just Santa reference signals out
to all these these smart appliances and
there'll be a it won't be perfect but we
don't care anyway it doesn't have to be
and I think we can do that you know and
so basically what I've skipped over is
just the fact that I think we can get
away with with just purely broadcast
nothing but broadcast from balancing
authority to all the appliances in
Southern California say I'm really
confident that that architects will work
I don't see a problem with that
so markets alright just give me three
minutes and and I will conclude so
there's this obsession with competitive
equilibrium for design and analysis of
electricity markets it was a mistake it
was a mistake it still is a mistake and
we've got to find a better way all right
so and one of the reasons it's a mistake
is right here the commodity of interest
to the consumer is hot water power is
completely invisible to the consumer it
makes no sense to pretend that they care
about power they kept an energy over
some period you know
the thing is that this marginal cost
framework has doesn't provide incentives
for investment basically it's low I
caught the science of death you paid
everybody just you know exactly the
marginal cost if they have they're lucky
and after the convicts cost function but
make a bit of profit but they don't make
any money for innovation nothing at all
for anything
and their son costs that billion dollars
for that generator is never paid for EDF
recognized it decades ago if you really
read his book he says this too so the
people siteswap a is pushing for
marginal cost real time prices he he
held he has text disputing this himself
so the thing is this risk all over the
place the generation the generation
generator operator once to know services
will be available they want to know this
20 megawatts they can grow they can shed
exactly and no more at this hour and
they want it to be available when you
know 10 years from now you know they
don't want people everyone to suddenly
decide to walk away and they need good
quality in terms of tracking otherwise
they'll need more of it and to what
consumers when I've already said it you
know they want to know if their power is
available is by Bill predictable that's
a big thing you know
all right bill I'm just to have my bill
and with real-time price and you never
would and the thing is a any rational
agent getting up this morning at least
in my apartment which is too cold you
want a hot shower and that's it and
maybe you know Balaji will tell you some
people in Berkeley need a nudge I don't
know but just look at this I'm insecure
just to pee in the statement look at the
difference between what the consumer
cares about that's the temperature and
the power consumption there's a real
water heater okay this is not some yeah
this is reality
why at earth would you do that so the
way people analyze pretty consumers in
the loop and put in markets is they
pretend a rational agent it's going to
maximize the the integral the utility of
power consumption - the price times a
generation it doesn't make sense
never do good sense and and so the
people like this because Lagrange
multipliers are so sexy I think that the
math is pretty but it doesn't make sense
so there's an issue contracts for the
industrial consumers which have long
term incentives inappropriate risk
allocation on long timescales and what
these guys around ten years from now not
just tomorrow and so this cost evaluate
calculations for real storage and
virtual energy storage and I think
that's it that's me after yes I think
real time markets make no sense because
because of the fact that we can look at
BPA there's see we can see a before and
after BPA doesn't have a real time
market it's a zero energy signal calling
the energy signal energy market is a lie
it never was energy market so it's just
I mean please I wish that the guys were
here you know Bornstein and and my
Lauren would be screaming at me right
now but I I've never gotten a scientific
argument and dispute what I just said
and I've had it today with economists
for fifteen years day ahead is getting a
bit more sensible but again is a issue
of some costs you know these these
companies have a staff that's a son cost
and they spend a billion dollars in that
equipment and none of that is part of
marginal cost you know so so thing is at
Hogan
hold a Hogan would say yes it is it's
all wrapped up that's not true the
theory doesn't support that claim the
theory of marginal cost pricing does not
does not let you pretend that your
interest payments that some cost is
marginal cost so it's claimed that it
gets in the end built in but that's not
valid and there are no incentives for
building these highly efficient
generators so I think thank you thanks
they will be
Texas you know Texas well we know the
clearing price the generators will bid
more than the market clearing price
receive the market price so they're
making good money but they're getting
$23 and they go an hour in Texas yes
it's not no it's not no it's not and the
things I can give another example so in
the Midwest so we have you know they'll
fix things as it goes along they'll keep
on putting band-aids to fix it so it in
the Midwest back before fracking we had
all coal generation and the problem was
they didn't the natural gas was
expensive so all the paper generators
are going to the business but they
needed the peaker plants they needed the
peaker plants francoise services they
needed for reserves and they were
scrambling to figure out artificial
means to keep these picker generators in
business the issue is that treating just
energy as a commodity is a mistake it's
a multi commodity product and so these
so you know and so yeah and so and so
today with more and more wind
these generators got a business and you
lose services that's that's what's going
to happen absolutely I mean I'm sorry I
got I said too many things there but we
did see it Midwest and the mirror of the
miracle was that fracking saved the
Midwest before all the peakers went out
of business but it was I can show you
articles from back in 2011 into
connections use auctions to guarantee
there will be a certain amount of
generation let's F so you receiving
annual payment just for being there
interesting question more how to design
so that's just in recognition of about
these price spikes and not enough
interesting problem and how to design
those capacity markets so that
participants of this might could get to
you know get some kind of bank income
and then some of this uncertainty yeah I
think I think that sort of architecture
might work you know something
will you make sure that you give some
incentive to be around and then you pay
for services and you should pay them for
the quality of services so they should
get they should get penalized if enough
tracking the signal arrests attract or
they're not available and they said they
would be but that would completely fight
that's not legal today
that's that's discrimination according
to the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission you're forced to treat all
power this the same even if it one is
boy high qualit in the other it's really
straight it's a strange situations are
there
but 71 in practice perk up the Texas
market has no capacity market and they
pride itself not hammer
New England has one but in the affecting
zero price or close to zero so I know
what is causing that but in practice it
seems like what is driving the planning
process is not but the thing is that I
don't understand by every other industry
we're willing to have a CEO model Delta
Airlines makes plans for 20 years in the
future and there's a market they put up
bids to the court for airplanes and and
generate and jet engines and all that
and there's a CEO and there's engineers
to make long-term decisions and there's
a market and it works really well and
Florida Power and Light and Duke Energy
they're this they're not perfect but
they do this long-term planning and
they've are the most efficient
generators in planet and we have very
cheap weights because of that why is it
every other field you'll out of a CEO
and not in the power sector
I just don't know so it's someone during
most of the energy is a tree under
bilateral yes that's two terms so that
may be relevant Eric questions of my
question is most of the markers they
don't really consider this even though
this is a big part of the energy so how
do I think about this electro agreement
which is is a marker they interact with
all these real time markers energy
markers capacity markers and so on which
he does vanity I to a small fraction
by a financial transmission rights to
hedge price risk you know some pretty
organized you know yeah in you know 60
70 percent wholesale our transactions
are bilateral but the thing is that it's
just a matter of accounting commerce
form not this is not it sounds like it
sounds like Venn Jellicle it's not if
you just look go to haircut any day
where is their car good haircut any day
I guess I'd you know at the beginning um
yeah yeah forget it the good is good ear
cut any day and you'll see this every
day so there's no way that this can
continue generators and are losing money
every day in in Texas and maybe there's
hope you felt lottery that there'll be a
crisis will get you know a billion
dollars oh no no this is I didn't look
for this oh no no we're good a haircut
right now it's like every minute always
every minute it's like this no no it's
always like this
okay I won't good I won't do it always
like this and the other thing I want to
do it I want to look I want to look at
the generation makes in California so
which has you know these real-time
markets versus Florida which has a
dictatorship a senior model we and what
the efficiency is of generation the in
Florida compared to California to the
Midwest I'll bet it's way more efficient
because who would invest in a
billion-dollar generator with all the
insurgency here
okay that's perfect
[Applause]